It's hard with the kids behind you
knowing that they're laughing at you
*The Yeti laughs*
It's not hard-
They didn't even notice... they didn't even
notice, they didn't even notice
Some of the people, they're in the Amsterdam sign, they noticed. They were looking at us a little bit
Yup! That's okay though.
*music plays*
Goedemorgen
(crowd says) Good morning Hank!
(Guy with puppet says) Good morning Hank!
Hank, it's Sunday. It's news day and the news today is that I went to Netherlands and I want to tell you about it.
So, Hank, I have just gotten home from a
week of touring Holland with two other
american authors, Jordan Sonnenblick and
Steve Cougar, and man it was fun!
God I love The Netherlands! I love its
public transportation, the amazingly nice
teachers lounges in its public schools,
its daring architecture, and of course
it's amazing cafes with their brilliant
bitter balls! Bitter balling!
Oh man Hank, I wish you had taste-o-vision
so you could know what happens when they
mix meat and hope and then fry it.
Hmmm, hope.
Oh Hank and also on this trip to The
Netherlands, I discovered a new amazing
Dutch delicacy! Tackenschlacken! By the
way I pretty much made up the name
Hawkinschalkin
It's a Dutch delicacy. It's white bread, butter and, uh,  chocolate sprinkles, so I'm gonna
It's delicious.
Really.
Some say it's the new bitterballs.
I mean Hank is the poet hath wrote "Ooh,
baby, do you know what that's worth?"
"Ooh, heaven is a place on Earth". And as if
all that weren't enough, on Thursday
night the city of Amsterdam was
inundated with more than 100 made-of-
awesome nerdfighters for an evening of
hilarity, fun, and me epically failing at
reading in Dutch.
*trying to read in Dutch*
Hank, look! *screams*
Hank, look, wooden shoes with Willy!
He's a pirate!
When I say "bitter" you say "balls"
BITTER
BALLS
Ooh, Accio Deathly Hallows
I mean, Hank, people were singing a song you wrote in a bar in Amsterdam.
Allow me to quote David after his visit
to the dentist.
I feel funny. Is this real life? Oh and Hank, one other story I was being interviewed by a journalist in Holland
and she said she'd read paper towns in both English and Dutch and then she said
"It was much better in Dutch" and then I was like "why?" and she said "much funnier".
So, Nerdfighters, if you can read in Dutch,
you should definitely buy Paper Towns
in Dutch, that way my publisher Lemniscaat
will bring me back over to Holland
and I can eat more bitterballen and more
hawkishshocking and I will live happily
ever after.
Okay Hank, there are a bunch of awesome links,
amsterdam-y and otherwise in the sidebar,
I will talk to you about the peeps eating
situation on Tuesday and now I have to
go sleep.
DFTBA!